The easiest way to answer the quiz would just be to do that experiment.
Let's try creating a set from the list where the element is the value 101,
that's the number and that works okay.
We'll do the second example as well, also, works okay.
Now, we'll try the third one where the element of the set is itself a set.
and now we get an error except for I got a different area than I expected which is that I called set here
with three arguments and it expected at most 1, so let's try that again.
We need to make a list of 1, 2, 3 as my set element and now I get a different kind of type error.
This is that I've tried to use an unhashable type set as an element of my set
and we can see that sets are unhashable.
Another way to see that will be used the built-in hash operator.
Hash takes an object and that's the 10 integer.
For an integer, hash maps 101 to 101. If we hash hash browns, we get this big integer.
If we hash some other string, we get a different one.
There would be some other strings that would hash to the same value
but it shouldn't be too easy to find.
But when we do a hash on a set, we get an error because it's an unhashable type.
It has no way to compute hash and since the value of a set can mutate,
it will be dangerous to use them in a dictionary or in a set itself
which is why we're not actually allowed to do that.
The other two examples, we had a tuple which works okay.
A tuple itself is immutable and we can see that t prints out as a tuple.
We can access elements of it just like we could in a list, but we can't do assignment.
As we solve the sets, well, that's not enough to know that it's immutable
because set also doesn't allow item assignment but is mutable.
The final one we had with set where the element is set itself.
That's okay and we can see a printout telling us what set means here is the type set.
Type is an object. We haven't talked about types in a formal way, in 101.
They are very important part of understanding Python programs
as you get to be a more advanced programmer.
Everything in Python has a type. We can see that type by using type.
So the type of a number is integer. The type of a string is the type string abbreviated str
and the type of the result of set is a set.
The type of set is the type type because set itself is a type and that's the type that set has.
Things can get pretty confusing and we're getting a little bit sidetracked.
So, we're going to go back to the question that we started with
of figuring out what we can do with sets.